clarity is power hey guys welcome to
another book edition I'm a little bit
sick today been sick for the past week
coughing fever headache probably really
shouldn't be outside today but got my
book got my videos you guys have always
been there for me and so I feel like you
know I gotta keep providing some great
content for you so I apologize if
today's video is not as clear as I'd
like it to be but I want to talk about
clarity and I feel like a lot of
entrepreneurs aren't clear enough when
they're working with suppliers when
they're bringing on a team what we
really want is for people to do things a
lot of times our way we're frustrated
that the people we bring onto people we
work with don't do it our way
you know don't have the same standards
don't follow our processes and then the
end result isn't something that we are
in love with and that may be in part
from having the wrong people that's fine
but it also may be from your lack of
clarity I'm not providing clear enough
instructions on how you want something
done and I faced this issue a number of
times in my business I look at the
YouTube channel as an example I hired
Ivan to come on board and help me with
all the research finding the top 10
quotes the video clips the expressive
video clips that's all I've been putting
together the research and when I first
hired him I gave him some general
instructions and I said hey find things
that that inspire you let that be
determining factor if it inspires you
it's it's good I want you to come away
feeling something strong and I found
that that was a good start but it wasn't
quite enough I wasn't clear enough and I
ended up doing a lot of editing of his
work and it still saved me a ton of time
in terms of me having to go and do it
all myself but I was I was removing a
lot of the stuff that he added I was
editing my own things putting in new
clips and still spending a lot of time
and so to provide more clarity we now
have a weekly meeting every Friday we
meet and go through one of his top 10
series together like recent what I would
do on my own and they explained to him
here's why I like this here's why I
don't like this you know what I'm
putting in when I'm taking out what the
order of the clips are sometimes why I
make extra
well why extend cliffs to give him
broader awareness knowledge contacts to
create something that is amazing for my
channel and you know what he likes is
maybe not you know great for my channel
qpp for his channel if you want to start
one but I'm trying to help him have more
clarity so he feels like he's doing a
better job how this relates to my book
section three and my book is all about
interviews section 1 and section 2 or me
my writing my thoughts my examples my
theories and the practical execution of
it section 3 I wanted to expand it to
show how other companies are doing it to
everybody from a guy who's making
$50,000 and as a full-time income to
companies making hundreds of millions of
dollars and kind of everywhere in
between so no matter what size business
you have there's at least one company
had to breathe there's one company that
you can look to as an example and doing
those interviews was fun but each
interview lasted four to five hours and
just the thought of sitting there and
transcribing those interviews and
putting them in the content to me felt
like an insane amount of time and it
wasn't necessarily my best skill set
either so I brought someone on board to
help me with the copywriting and I've
always had a hard time finding some
working right in my voice
I've never be able to find someone who
can write as me I end up just editing
and rewriting it and so anything that
you see kind of written form its me
that's me writing it and so maybe I'll
get to that for and if we don't find
someone but it could be my lack of
clarity food for thought anyway so in
terms of of the book the person I
brought on board did a great job of
transcribing and putting the the content
together but when I went in and read it
I just didn't flow with the rest of the
book you know I think she was putting a
lot of her style and I gave some
overview of what to do some general
directions and guidelines but not enough
it wasn't clear enough and so the third
section the book had some great content
but it didn't flow with the raster
didn't seem like it was coming from me
it wasn't part of the rhythm of the book
and so not that it was wrong I just you
know I want to feel proud about the
stuff that I put out I think you should
too if you need to have high standards
and it may be so hard that nobody else
cares maybe I could put it out as it was
and you guys would love it anyway but I
want to love what I do with the videos
with the book with the projects I'm
working on I want to look at it and be
proud of what I made be able to show my
son and my grandkids
point not grandkids yet but you know
what I'm talking about to be proud of
what I'm making and so again what helped
here was more clarity so we hopped on a
number of calls together and said here's
exactly what I'm trying to do here's how
I want to open every page here's how I
want to close every page I want to have
it broken down in the following way and
once I gave that clarity she was able to
rock and roll
she was able to pound out more pages I'm
making very minimal edits and changes
and I think it saves everybody
frustration because she's frustrated
that you know I'm rejecting the pages
I'm saying that's not good enough I'm
making edits and changes and I made
specific changes of that kind of giving
the guidelines if you're working with
the team of people and you have a
specific result in mind and you have
specific criteria and you have high
standards you know when they're not
delivering to the standards and
capabilities that you're looking for one
that may be that you have the wrong
people in place but two you want to make
sure that you've given every opportunity
to them to provide clarity provide
training provide mentorship because if
you can be more clear you're more likely
to get the result that you want let me
get to your questions okay first up is
Amir you mentioned this is your first
book but did you not write your zuga
series yeah the Lucas series I guess was
officially my first written series but
it was never put into a book format
those are all worksheets that are sold
individually or as a package this is my
first real book and it's with the
publishers with penguin Random House so
that's why I call it my first book
Frances very inspiring advice there are
many ideas that I've researched and
taking action on yet many people my
environment do not have the same
interest do you have any advice on how
to network with other entrepreneurs
around the area I've many ideas that I
know will make money after exhausting
hours of research but do not know anyone
with the same interest desires to learn
more so I think with this you just got
to explore you got to explore get
involved in communities some of them
maybe online communities doesn't have to
be in your local area that could be I
guess depend on the business kind though
that you're trying to launch I think too
many people settle they settle for good
you find someone who kind of has the
same interest and then you get your
hopes up you get all excited and then
you know they I'm gonna make it work
with this person and then it's not the
right person if you settle then you're
never gonna find great good is the enemy
agreed I think I talked about that in
last week's episode so just get involved
in things
you know whatever target mark you're
trying to get into there are meetup
groups their communities their
associations get involved go out there's
gonna be a lot of people who won't fit
your criteria and that's okay just keep
moving
don't settle keep searching keep
exploring get involved in every offline
and online community that you can be
involved in that you can think of until
you find the right people and when you
find that person then you go all in and
and make it happen
so stop settling Rajeev sir I think
ideas are like a bubble it increases
with a lot of air then suddenly due to
environment in circumstances of births
how does it survive is a big question
and only believe works I'm not fully
understanding the question there you
know ideas grow and then suddenly do new
environment and circumstances it busts
you know I do agree that environment
does hold a lot of people by the people
around you you know just look at your
daily environment that your routines
your habits I think the first thing is
just recognition and awareness that your
environment holds you are I think until
you recognize that there is a problem
you're not gonna fix it people who have
addictions of people who are invited
relationships it's only when you realize
that this is a problem that's that's
when you start to change it and so I
challenge you to look at your
environment and see what are the what
are the problems of the people you're
hanging out with is it your morning
routine is that the music you listen to
is it your actual physical environment
you know what is it that is holding you
back and then start making changes once
you want them to find the problem it's
easier to make the changes I wouldn't
blame circumstances because that's an
excuse it's easy to blame circumstances
you look at any successful entrepreneurs
are the most successful people who have
built insane companies most of them
started with nothing they started with
nothing so it's not blaming the
circumstances and saying oh you know I
can't be successful because of whatever
you know my parents weren't successful
or I don't speak English well or I was a
born in America or I don't have the
right education whatever as long as you
tell yourself that story then that's
always going to be your story you're
never gonna be successful circumstances
are not the main issue but your
environment and the story tell yourself
are so work on that and the good news is
that's totally within you can try
you can change the story you tell
yourself you can change environment
that's around you to create one that is
more nurturing supportive of your big
ideas to help them grow and keep growing
and not burst like a balloon
Antoine wrote in to say what about the
process of writing the book when do you
know you've researched enough for
specific topic and actually start
writing
that's a cool point I think for me the
products that I created the videos I
curate the books I create the t-shirts
that I create everything that create is
based on me scratching my own itch like
I'm genuinely curious about this stuff I
want to create something that I'm proud
of it makes me come alive and it's ready
when I feel like it's ready you know
it's a gut feel kind of thing a lot of
the things in the book
I have put in because I've experienced
them and they've rapidly helped me grow
businesses I had to then go out and
research other companies that I've done
it as well right I had the things that
I've had an intuition about and had to
see he does this work for other people
and that's what led to section 3 and all
the interviews and their case studies
and examples and so for me when is a
product done it's when you're proud of
it it's when you want to release it
whether that's a book whether that
software whether that's a new car
whether that's whatever it is that
you're working on
I would keep tinkering keep working away
until I had something that I was proud
of and ready to release that being said
it's never done like it's never done and
I think that holds a lot of people back
because they want it to be perfect it's
never going to be perfect you can have
something that you're proud of that
makes you come alive that's not perfect
because I'm sure when I write the book
and release it already those sections
that I want to add that I don't have the
time to add that might be part of a new
book or something when you're excited
about something and you're proud of it
and you feel like this adds value you
release it but don't wait for it to be
perfect next I've done I'm assumed to be
divorced mother form besides my
religious type videos your videos really
keep me motivated to be the best I can
be you're very much one of the virtual
mentors to me so awesome life-changing
Don really appreciate that
you know I'm really sick today and it's
because of people like you in the car
that I get that makes me keep going I
really love what I do so I really
appreciate that I'm glad that I could be
a small part of your journey and I want
you to know that you're a part of my
journey too so appreciated reishi cup TV
I love this channel helps give me
confidence to go for the crazy ideas I
posted a crazy idea on my channel today
and this video gave me a little bit of
confidence that the video completely
fails oh well at least I can continue to
say I went for it and tried I think
that's the important thing you want to
make sure that you give your ideas a try
you don't have to be so attached to it
to an idea that if it doesn't work out
then you know your personal ego is at
stake and your personal you know
self-confidence and you feel like a
failure just because your idea didn't
work it doesn't mean that you are a
failure and I think the worst thing is
just having these ideas and not do
anything with them I was having a chat
yesterday with the guy I brought on to
run the salsa business with me and I've
tested a new crazy idea out in front of
the studio that he didn't like and he
says it's too crazy and he doesn't
understand how it ties into what we're
doing and that's cool
and you know I'm totally willing to have
that idea fail it may fail I may suck it
may be the worst thing that I've ever
come up with but I had the idea and I
need to give it a shot that's what you
need to do you know you have to be
willing to try big things and be willing
to fail at it even if it's not even if
you're not investing a lot like don't
say you have to go out and take out a
loan and go all-in and put your your
house and your family on the line go do
a small start and try and see what
happens see if it makes you come a lot
see if you start getting some results
because the worst thing is having an
ambition a dream a big idea and then
just sitting on it because you're afraid
that it's going to fail or you're afraid
of what people are gonna think about you
next up Tamra thank you for answering my
question every great advice do your one
hundred twenty thousand words includes a
surprise chapter six yeah so the book is
about 120 thousand words right now
that's all in it's going to go through
some major editing I still have the
let's base what I'm doing right now
editing if we end up taking some words
out then I don't know what I'm gonna do
with it it might be free content on the
website and maybe videos that I created
maybe content for another book but yeah
the 120 is everything including the
surprise end of chapter 6 and then last
up I know a number of you guys comment
about the video freezing last week's
video I apologize for that we've been
having a lot of struggle with the
YouTube channel recently with videos
freeze it for some reason I don't know
what what's happening why that's the
problem I know
christina is really frustrated by it
we've had to upload and re-upload a
number of videos because for whatever
reason it froze we haven't fully
understood why it's happening this one
kind of slipped through psychologize for
that and we'll try to do a better job
next time if you guys have any resources
tips ideas and why that might be
happening I'm all ears too and I'm sure
Christina would love the advice too so
that's it I am out of breath my arms are
tired I'm feeling sick physically but
I'm feeling nourished in my soul and so
thank you for spending your time today
with me if you have a question or
comment about providing clarity which
was the topic of today's session or you
have a question about your book my book
the book writing process leave it in the
comments below and I will make a video
reply for you on next week's video thank
you guys for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon